the gorilla t-shirt is a joke when alex
jones was on the show
he kept saying i am a gorilla kill
yourself well we didn't like that why
well because the it's based on this book
called ishmael where this like spirit
was in a spirit gorilla
so wait a minute let me get this
straight your big t-shirt idea was
something alex jones said on your show
wow
wow yeah i know that is the site he
stole from his brother him and cassandra
fairbanks they're such good people
um now there is going to be some gems
because i was watching this before the
show and there is some very funny stuff
in here
um but yeah you just stole it from alex
and he straight up says it like that
that's why i'm starting to think tim
poole might be
we might have to put him in the category
with kraut oh sorry
uh with crowder
because like crowder guys like crowder
and guys like tim poole
and some of these dudes um they they do
these things that are like
completely psychotic
but they just do it and then like like
there are people that do [ __ ] that's
scummy
and and and it's you know um
completely like you could call it out
and go that's a scummy move right
but there are people that will do
something scummy but still have the
sense that the sense of like trying to
hide it
the self-awareness to go i know what i
did is scummy
so i don't want people to ever find out
that i did the scummy thing
but like tim's one of those guys that
will describe to you that he's doing a
scummy thing
and then you go like what why would you
tell me that
so look like alex jones came in and said
something that we
so we stole it and put it on a t-shirt
and then so eye contact teespring and
you're going
wait wait wait wait wait back up
wait tell me the part where you said you
stole the thing and put it on his shirt
well yeah yeah of course like he said a
thing it was on my show so
yeah we took his uh we stole his essence
and put it into a shirt but anyway my
point is so
teespring printed it and then you're
like no no i'm not done
i want to hear the part where you talk
about
you stole a thing and you're completely
okay with it
you know most people would you'd go the
gorilla thing didn't you steal that from
alex jones no
i was saying that years ago before that
was something i was doing and then you
know alex was
alex was quoting me actually you know
but he's just like yeah so i stole this
thing from alex
anyway i hate that i hate him so much
man
this guy was like seeking the meaning of
life he finds this gorilla who
has telepathic powers and talks to him
telepathically okay like guerrilla grodd
from dc i guess i don't know
he's a villain he's basically what
telling people that they're like a virus
well yeah he's explaining that humans
have kind of ended up becoming too
too much of takers in the world yeah
it's almost like
human beings are the real virus man
wow that's deep i bet it [ __ ] smells
in that studio
my other issue that i forgot to bring up
earlier too was
like you see this which again very
shitty proof very shitty job
there's a reason why it came out like
this but
um the the blackface thing nobody said
that
tim said that and tried to make a big
deal so he can try to bully
teespring into doing something for him
and also get generate some controversy
but
it's one of those things where you go
you see that
blackface and i go i don't see blackface
like i was joking earlier
nobody wants to see blackface more than
me because
blackface is hilarious i could just sit
here and make al jolson references for
an hour and we get all left
but like it's it's not like
you're seeing blackface where there is
no blackface it's it's like look there
are two types of people right there are
people
that see racism everywhere where there
is none
white liberals that see racism
everywhere
the ones that call you know ben carson
and uncle tom
a sleepy and meanwhile he's a
neurosurgeon who grew up poor
um the people that call you and uncle
tom and [ __ ] on you for voting
republican the people that will scream
at you and say racist [ __ ] to you
because you don't vote democrat right
the people that see racism everywhere
are usually racists they're usually
consumed by and obsessed with
race so if you're thinking about race
all day
then you're like oh my god blackface and
you're like where did
what like did you see this
huh look at this blackface and you're
like
you see an african-american guy in that
on that shirt
because you might that's pretty [ __ ]
up you might be the [ __ ] up one
golden we're kind of destroying the
planet now instead of
how we're supposed to go symbiotically
with it okay okay
so ian ended up saying
love yourself and so we thought that was
funny people in the chat kept saying i'm
a girl and posting gorilla emojis
and i liked the idea of focusing on
getting back to nature you know being
responsible for yourself because
you know when we had jack murphy here i
mentioned what ishmael is kind of about
and when i said it's you know get back
to nature and you know get in the
wilderness maybe chop some lump
by the way temples
[Laughter]
i didn't realize how many people hate
tim poole his whole
chat room where people just spamming
gorilla emojis
[Laughter]
these people are absolute [ __ ]
[ __ ]
number jacks like that sounds pretty
good you know what i mean and so i'm
like let's make a positive thing
i don't do political shirts luke does
political shirts look at the shirt he's
wearing right now well well i get my
shirt censored but that's a whole nother
story though
but luke's got political shirts it's or
it's orwell saying boyd did i call it or
what
it's a great choice who would wear that
who would wear that you know everybody
has
a t-shirt idea and
a lot of them are terrible i'll have you
guys know
a lot of your t-shirt ideas are really
bad because there's there are some gems
in this episode
well the tim can
and on purpose we have one where it says
silence accelerates victory it's the old
slogan from the u.s office of censorship
it's about as political as we get
and and the pyramid you know with the
great with the austin eye being toppled
over that was before
irl right yes that was something i made
a while ago as just like it's
i thought was cool it's like the
censorship being knocked over we'll win
that's about as political as we get
because we have a cat we've got me with
a pipe with bubbles coming up and shirts
with beanies on them that's right you
buy a shirt got a beanie on it
so when we made the i am a gorilla shirt
i put tim cast irl on it and it's meant
to just
be a silly thing for the fans people
listen to the show
no strong message i'm about to show you
an image most of you probably have
already seen me tweet about it
because when i saw this i was just like
i face-palmed i'll admit
you know i'm i'm a pretty chill person
so i was laughing but i was like
still kind of worried at this some has
anybody ever used
the word chill to describe
temple has anybody ever said oh tim
pooley that guy's mad
chill
tim nobody thinks you're a chill dude
nobody
your cadence the rapid fire
um rhythm at which you speak
your wound up neurotic [ __ ] delivery
your need to have the last word your
your constant
little neurotic [ __ ] obsessions over
yourself
tim you sell food buckets and tell
people the civil war is coming
nobody thinks you're chill
nobody's like oh tim poole he's such a
chill guy
not tim pool man he's so [ __ ] chill
man
timmy boy bro i was telling but i was
hanging out with tim bro
he's so chill when somebody goes i'm a
pretty chill person but
it's just like it's just like when
somebody goes look
i like to joke around just as much as
anybody like look i have a great sense
of humor everybody says i'm such a funny
guy
but like i don't joke about dude that's
not funny
you know that guy look man everybody
says like i'm
dude trust me i love jokes you know
people say i got a real twisted sense of
humor but like
i don't appreciate racism bro like wait
a minute what
i love that it's like when somebody
works at an office is like oh you're
gonna love it here yeah it's like your
first day at the new
accounts receivable and everybody's like
oh you're going to love it here dude
we all really like to joke around bro
we have real sick senses of humor around
here
he's so chill dude tim poole's so chill
he's such a chill guy
tim tim timmy tim look at me
look at me and look i have some
self-awareness i get it i'm a drunk i'm
a degenerate
i'm a loser i'm not doing as good as you
in the [ __ ] algorithm and then that's
fine whatever you're better at gaming in
the system than me and
and that's fine tim
you're a [ __ ] nerd that's what you
are
you're a [ __ ] nerd nobody thinks
you're chill
nobody nobody thinks you're chill
you're one of the biggest youtubers
around and you can't even get [ __ ]
unless it's like sloppy looking day
shift looking girls little chicken
nugget looking
okay nobody thinks you're chill
and if anybody's telling you that you're
a chill guy okay
they're lying to you for clout
me find let me make sure i got this
pulled up
there we go thank you ogre
i'm gonna need ogre to back me up here
because it's it's it's
impossible to to um
it's impossible to deal with tim pool
without having some nerds
[Laughter]
no i'm a chill guy they're not they're
definitely not talking about me
the guy who wore a [ __ ] beanie to the
white house nah has to be some other
it has to be some other totally less
chill guy
someone ordered this shirt one of the
first
shirts to go out and this is what
happened ladies and gentlemen
i give you the sabotage of the i am a
gorilla shirt i am offended
the i am a guerrilla meme was supposed
to be fun and silly and family friendly
and it is just a drawing of a silly
cartoon gorilla sitting there like here
i'm a gorilla it doesn't mean anything
well here's the image i got on the left
you can see the original artwork wait is
he acting is he trying wait is this a
bit or not
is this a bit he he's doing a bit right
i'm starting to maybe be convic
help me out here i'm i'm very good at
reading these situations
but i'm having trouble reading this one
because he's flipping back and forth
between actually angry and then like
doing a bit and i can't again i have
trouble reading people
that are this sociopathic sometimes but
i i need to see this again um
someone ordered this shirt one of the
first
shirts to go out and this is what
happened ladies and gentlemen
i give you the sabotage of the i am a
gorilla shirt i am offended
the i am a gorilla meme was supposed to
be fun and silly and family friendly
and it is just a drawing of a silly
cartoon gorilla sitting there like yeah
i'm a gorilla it doesn't mean anything
well here's the image i got on the left
you can see the original artwork
on the right you can see what was
delivered to someone who ordered the
shirt
for those that are listening i said yo
teespring you want to tell me why our
cartoon gorilla shirt became an effing
blackface drawing
how was this an accident his hands were
printed white and his face was darkened
this is the crazy thing about it a lot
of people have suggested
that this was some kind of printing
error it wasn't
now the first thing i want to say i've
talked with teespring and they're
working on solving
figuring out what happened and it is
definitely on their end
but so is it a bit or not
i smell a hint of sarcasm for furious
george and i i do too like he's doing
like to be fair this is something
that i'll completely admit right now
that i would absolutely do like
if i made a shirt like that and it came
out like that
i would totally like like the same way i
did with ubereats where i was like you
really think
indians aren't people that's offensive
like
but it seems like he can't commit to
whether or not it's a joke in a bit or
if it's
serious that's the thing i don't
understand like
and that's that's why i'm confused right
is he doing a bit because if he's doing
a bit then like yeah it's a bit i would
i would do that bit but then i'm not
trying to be serious food bucket guy
like i'm not trying to be news guy
so what are you trying to do
not a bit he's looking to sue take
advantage of the situation
that's what i mean but it's it's
he's actually angry but he's trying to
make it a bit maybe i
i don't know but it's
see mexi man and cheese has a good not a
bit he's trying to make fun of sjws
while acting like them that's what i
mean like this is
i'm very confused by this i am
i really you know i should have known
better i didn't realize
i since it's not a q and on day i didn't
think i would need this pulled up at all
times
but apparently i'm gonna need this
about six beers deep so i think you're
gonna have to
be a little bit more clear because i
didn't get that last part i i missed out
on the whole thing to be honest with you
i was confused by it i'm very confused
by the
i was very confused by the whole thing
to be if i'm being honest
it's it's i don't know what i don't know
what direction he's trying to go with
this
but not through their main uh company
what they told me that they believe
this came from a third party that they
outsourced to
no it definitely hey stupid it
definitely came from a third party
teespring isn't [ __ ] running a giant
t-shirt factory
oh chunka chunka a chunka chunka that's
not what's happening you
stupid [ __ ] beanie wearing [ __ ]
what happens is
every company vista print teespring any
of these [ __ ] third-party web fiverr
all these websites
act as a middleman amazon amazon didn't
make the desk that i'm sitting on
amazon didn't make my board amazon
didn't make
the monitors or all the [ __ ] that's in
there they didn't make it
it's not their fault if it's broken
they're a middleman tim you [ __ ] you
dumb [ __ ]
so they they go all right what do you
need you need this boom and they forward
it and they get some [ __ ]
or some [ __ ] somebody to print the
[ __ ] up
and send it out tim apparently they're
using third-party
yes you dumb [ __ ] it's what they do
that's why
the [ __ ] that's why i've got two joe
biden shirts because they [ __ ] up the
one
and then the second one doesn't even fit
me because it's european sized
because they have a european one too tim
and you also sent shitty artwork you
dumb [ __ ]
uh look i respect teespring i like them
i've sold shirts with them for a long
time
and i have no issues with them so i
respect they called me and they were
really apologetic and they were like we
really want to get to the bottom of this
yeah what's what you want
being called racists and i was like i
don't i don't want people walking around
with tim cast irl branding
and this ridiculous image let me explain
something this is a picture of
of what looks like some uh it looks like
a minstrel costume
because the fists were changed to be
white the face
is blackened but you can see the where
the black on the faces it doesn't reach
all the way to the end of the face
kind of like black face so some people
said it was a printing error oh
i don't know how that was mine because
you can see that they're certainly tim
you don't know how to be a printing
error because you're not a
[ __ ] screen printer you dumb [ __ ] oh
my god he is he really is trying to
[ __ ] with teespring